today I'm gonna show man should get
strained with that distress and Deadpool
goes right off Main Street all the
appellant's a lot more fat man on
Batman's about to begin
well in the fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith mark Barnard a know what happened
to our graphic I don't know which words
now we used to have a cool cartoon we
just we blocked it out and now it's just
all words and should I know Oh weird you
know I couldn't afford the cartoon I
like the yellow TC call was that it
they're like I can use Batman in the
logo the horns are bad welcome to the
plane this is like the version of
Cheerios that my mom used to buy a food
town toasted oats you tune in for fat
man I'm Batman and you got generic these
are like that robot jerseys of Logan I
don't know what happened I guess we're
not pulling in the numbers because now
we're this is graphic don't [ __ ]
matter it's not what you see behind us
it's what's gonna happen right here on
the mic man I'm sufficiently baked he's
sufficiently smart we're ready to
[ __ ] start this go right up Main
Street a new phrase we all I know
exemple drilling rental of geekdom and
comic news and all that stuff man me
marker about to make it happen before we
do anything else Mon what is on not that
your race this is yeah well I mean
that's cool too what come on easy he
gets shitty when he posts like sometimes
he gets mean so that's worth watching
but come on look at that
look at that runes [ __ ] we were just
talking about this couple episodes ago
what does it look like the drawing now
we see what it looks like man good
doctor strange doctor vo5 do you see
every hair follicle of Benedict
Cumberbatch is accounted for ladies and
gentleman look at that count'em you
cannot the my uncle Chad Benedict's use
hand number 523 is out of plays you want
to find your your Zen your piece of
place your face a pleat place a piece
whatever count every [ __ ] single
strand of hair on Benedict Cumberbatch's
hair in this [ __ ] in these pictures
it's crazy it's rented within an inch of
its life he also does magic and I know
but most of us like if I do magic hands
unless somebody's like I'm gonna put a
dick in it later on and [ __ ] put it
to his face it don't do it looks weird
he did magic hands
he did this [ __ ] like he didn't magic
and yeah but like it was almost like
like that like it starts here but using
this hand as a channel instrumental
exact and then we put lightning bolts
into his [ __ ] hands and [ __ ]
cuz this come on that's magic we've been
promised the most psychedelic [ __ ]
Marvel film we've ever seen to date well
then gently their quarrel [ __ ] magic
let's let's talk about this is let's go
to a single Barry let's talk about as
big news ah this is these gestures says
Benedict Cumberbatch in the actual
article says these gestures are a way of
creating the magic it's beautiful thing
it's balletic it's very dynamic and once
the boys in the backroom get to work on
it there's gonna be some crazy [ __ ]
going on the boys in the backroom know
that means well alright this crazy [ __ ]
comes no doubt what does the background
means that this dude's like smart enough
he's like look kids I'm gonna be doing
this but they're gonna be making a magic
there's nine thousand people in tiny
little black boxes making things go wee
you ain't kidding you know everything
you love about iron man that's not
Robert Downey jr. those cats are you
look at that [ __ ] in my hands the hands
in a number [ __ ] you know that the 12
minutes you've got to sit through before
you get to the post credit tag those
guys yeah that's gonna be nuts this
movie I'm telling you man I the director
is good old Scott Derrickson I had him
on an episode of smoothie makers at once
you go listen to it on spine cast come
what a great got great interview but he
was talking about this then really yeah
yeah and he's got he's got some vision
for it man but it's look whether Scott's
got vision on I believe it does because
I talked to the man Kevin Feige is be
gonna beat vision into him because Kevin
he's got a vision for this movie's crazy
says when this comic appeared in the
early sixties Kevin Feige says it really
informed in a way that is pretty amazing
a lot of the psychedelic 60s as we know
it did you think that's well free love
began with dr. Stephen strange I thought
they were just smoking on a lot in the
Marvel opposites excels and I look
Stanley hey Stanley do you happy touch
it is his birthday well you did so after
it was we were shooting it on his
birthday happy birthday stand 90 [ __ ]
three years old creators relevant
creator of Doctor Strange yes at the end
of modern mythology him man who else has
worked on doctor Street dico dico is a
dick oh wow spider-man spider-man team
those guys man did they ever do anything
else together just spider-man strange or
didn't who was no Kirby was cat but
that's crazy
yeah uh this isn't like that
we all went hushed we were like to stand
oh my god this is like maybe the only
property other than [ __ ] Stan is
spider-man and maybe romance comics or
whatever the [ __ ] were funny animal
comics that those two worked on that is
now a viable film property I've talked
about like the TV 70s TV movie I've seen
a few people on Twitter or like I don't
know that existed now I looked up as you
said that and holy the [ __ ] it's pretty
well yeah it's pretty
I mean it's we had kids it's no Dolph
Lundgren Punisher but you know what it's
at least they had a little skull on the
knife you know what it's like it's like
it's it's akin to a [ __ ] when you've
gone the distance and done it all and
then you look back at it and you're like
well who would waste their time or blah
blah blah it's a stepping stone it's a
stepping stone the TV movie Doctor
Strange is stepping stones the cinematic
one just took thirty [ __ ] years ago
this stepping stone handy there it is
nice well Quinn Lee thanks mom will be
so proud he says chem foggy continues I
don't know what they were doing
anything weird and the Bopanna marvel
but certainly the stuff they were doing
inspired all those people who are doing
mind expansion experiments at the time
so that's inherent to the property and
that's our mission statement for the
visual effects on this movie I like the
Kevin Feige as I go remember all those
astral warriors from the 60s it's our
fault it's kind of crazy like he's
taking credit I mean look I know Marvel
could do anything but rewrite history
this will be an interesting one I'm a
magic dragon more than a Doctor Strange
he's lame
we need LSD Timothy Leary bunny actually
probably this predates when was their
creation what year did they pop up 60
word 64 and may have a point man well it
might all been madmen right up until
doctors start sucking dick and smoking
weed sometimes simultaneously I think's
got why no hop that works dude we got a
real glad they like you my eyeball
there's no place for this dirtiness um
this this happens a visual sequence we
saw a picture of that was from when dr.
strange the very first meets the ancient
one played by Tilda Swinton man there it
is it's gonna be cosmic it's gonna be
trippy it's gonna be like a like an
album cover it's gonna like spending two
hours in a black light painting the same
any eloquently put man Mads Mikkelsen
role is the main villain
cuz that dudes never gonna be a hero
again you think so well I mean he's
gonna be like maybe in a Darth Vader way
he's like I've been redeemed he's the
guy who played Jame Gumb like that dude
there's not gonna be like the principal
of the schooling always weird you can't
talk about students that way as a
principal of the school put the books in
the library on the name of the villain
I've seen lots of names thrown around
hmm says uh executive producer Steven
Broussard I think no one has quite
picked the name that we've chosen for
him it would be fun to conceal that if
we can I have a guess go Phil Phil
crackin the Irish villain from space
honey likes to wedge it um I'm going
with Dormammu you think so come on dude
he's [ __ ] with us and he's telling us
it's Dormammu I think it's just a guy
I'm gonna want I'm gonna insist this
Dormammu and it's not terminal
disappointment destroy man outrage and
then be like those people going after
force awakens because why I don't know
because kings whatever kids some [ __ ] is
just to be hugged and loved like a puppy
yes
a good time oh my god listen listen it's
a world of puppies neuter me
good time there you go yeah that's
coming from [ __ ] mark barnard kids
all vodka straight up have a good time I
am this [ __ ] over blog rachel mcadams is
in his movie that's all we really know
he's playing a lady person he's planning
she playing a lady hmm
well the sure she could play a man cuz
he's got again till the sweatin is
playing that rolls earlier not sure
maybe this movie's a whole movie full of
like these women are such good actions
they're all playing man it's like a
reverse Shakespeare [ __ ] sex blind
casting umm so you did say sex blind I
did say sex play
I know now you go sex blind too much
yeah do much gracious Handy's too much
of that what Stefan stone Andy's um we
don't know who she can apply it but
she's not playing someone super no not
yet no apparently she's sort of dr.
Strange's contemporary in the modern New
York world before and after he goes on
his she's gonna be from the medical
world probably but if he's a doctor
she gotta be a nurse if she's a nurse
she could be a night nurse there's more
than one right there's the three night
nurses I believe there's the want Claire
mmm then there's two others Claire is
the one we all know from Rosario
Netflix Marvel TV shows so she might be
playing another one and of course like
it's got to be you could be both [ __ ]
horseshit if only one nurse treated
every goddamn Marvel here you know ran
like gotta be a couple here people
stumbling and operating theatres like
Christ I'm dying
do they ever team up the night nurses
yes because I would watch the [ __ ] out
of like Russ Meyer presents that night I
mean it's just me holy heaven rachel
mcadams rosario Dawson and
third one uh who I don't know what's
Eliza do I suggest Eliza Dushku they say
but they've saved the best for that
Faster Pussycat heal ha ha I would watch
this [ __ ] um yeah man told or I would
literally just watch even if they did
like you can't I don't know you could
definitely do a series on it but do a
feature every once in a while where they
just yeah hang out like Sex in the City
style they'll tell [ __ ] operating
room stories things do you ever see the
Punishers dick good idea like that it's
like cauliflower she could be a moran
there could be a Miranda Samantha type
you know I like this for my mom my mom
could grab on to where they just talk
about superheroes and never see them
guys an ass and they talk about them and
like in relatable ways where my mom was
like my your dad's dick was giant too
I'm like mom have you ever had a blind
lover she's like me and your father did
some of that blind casting look at the
sign sex connects pocket all right we
don't know whom rachel mcadams gonna
play but now don't [ __ ] matter this
movie's happening it's happening for
real people Mattel me get close to the
mic I can't get closer than this this
this is I go like no every time I move
it yeah it's like a Jesus picture did
you feel like this at the time I try to
get away um okay I can't wait oh yeah
and only a year from now is that it yeah
like next December thanks he done really
mm-hmm
good enough man gives them look there's
some [ __ ] to do before them I guess and
I'll be doing it but but people over
there with [ __ ] it bells on for this
only 378 more days until dr. stern is
there a Star Wars movie between now it
was a Batman V Superman there's Civil
War
there's monitors that you drove one is
like two weeks before Doctor Strange
really yeah bitching about nothing I
love it all I love it all um yeah it'll
be here before you know it kids [ __ ] I
remember the day they
announced JJ Abrams's as the director of
Star Trek and then Star Wars I mean a
Star Wars sort yeah he's just moving
right to the stars that's true what's
our search our search season is like oh
my god watch them win we all win when
they win you know I hate actors because
I wasn't saw the third time well yeah
force awakens third time so positive you
are I want to know those don't know the
characters in the movie
one moment very throwaway but such a JJ
Abrams kind of thing where Finn's like
they're both of the Millennium Falcon
Finn and Daisy and Friends like I could
do this I could do this and then you cut
up to her in the cockpit she's like I
could do this I could do this they would
never do that in the 70s you know I said
like Lucas would never say I can do this
very powerful man power faster and more
intense somebody sometimes that's the
secret to to positivity or to success
they say is like some people have to say
[ __ ] out left saying it out loud
reinforces it will tell her it will -
will - power
say it again gurus will it will to power
is a signature his own signal for that
is important which will be my
super-hearing we look to power that's
power
max power or will to power Imagi power
like Mads Mikkelsen
oh I was going to check that name you'll
only play bad guys you'll never play -
Mads max mad it's his dog dog I've been
basing my whole life to play this rule I
can't wait for this flick meanwhile in
Entertainment Weekly as well yeah baby
hey you know you dig deep enough you'll
find more gold look at this no no no you
were right the first time
yeah man when twins at that light
they're over their lives over that
middle finger that's to you that's Jon
Bernthal and your first look at the
Punisher
Frank Castiglioni there he is there's
the Punisher he's talking to daredevil
he's got him tied up man this looks like
the [ __ ] comics except he doesn't
have a skull on a shirt yet buy it
it's daredevil so they'll take a whole
season to get it on his chest and when
it happens you'd be like oh I actually
like the old about it better it's just
black with a jacket and a wrench
otherwise version I love this [ __ ]
show I could tease it but I [ __ ] love
it but I couldn't believe I when they
showed me the black costume first I was
like man
and a whole series of this and then
that's what you want oh it was crazy
well it's just the character drama is so
[ __ ] good they know what they're
doing over there mark they know what we
want Marvel television and according to
this they really know what they're doing
they show a picture on the next page
yeah that's kind of Internet show this
is where we read magazine remember those
kids it's like a morning show
good morning Alberta look what I read in
okay today there I looked away something
like there that in the corner well
that's how you get under general weekly
yes juveniles [ __ ] they got good stunned
with a male look at look at this right
there that's my name is elektra natchios
and I think that's what the second time
we've ever had in a lecture I think so
well Jennifer Garner was a freshman this
lady looks I don't know if she is Greek
but she certainly looks more Greek her
name is Elodie yung first name LOD LOD
ie last name y ung so I think she's
somewhat by Rachel in the neighborhood
enough to get you to swarthy um this
come on dude we're gonna see [ __ ]
Electra in the show and Frank Castle as
the Punisher who knows what else man
goddamnit forget the new Entertainment
Weekly's I know a lot of kids are like
[ __ ] you I'll read it online go by -
paper edition because you don't want
that you're gonna want to save that and
look this is like [ __ ] spank material
right there not her the [ __ ] fact
that there's Matt Murdock Karen page
playing they're getting friendly orchids
I know and they're getting friendlier
you know what happened to Karen page in
the comics I don't tell you some fat
[ __ ]
spoilers killed her off yeah but you
know they've got hands and balls so
everybody wins
oh the sexiest sport it is right there's
balls everywhere there's a lot of
leaning but it's not sexy if you're like
I'm not a ball person what if you're a
eunuch oh my gosh game reminds me of
what I've lost
there's lots of pockets to shop oh my
god let's start talking about the
Deadpool trailer yeah
right now right up Main Street funnest
[ __ ] totally there it is we're done go
watch it right now it's fantastic look I
I'm gonna say it here and it's not like
you know [ __ ] I've got the necessary
necessarily to say so you're but you
can't it's your show I'll try mmm and
I'm speaking for all the internet if not
all of humanity when I say this least
you Tom [ __ ] let up on Ryan Reynolds
for the Green Lantern cuz he's [ __ ]
over delivered on this Deadpool film
yeah I haven't even seen it and based on
the trailers alone I'm like this may be
the greatest motion ever made it's crazy
a tone is pitch perfect he is perfectly
cast the costume looks [ __ ] great
classes isn't it the latest trailer mmm
easily there's an x-men like reference
he calls him an ex don't get all x-men
or something like that yeah I'm good
time I'm being a good boy and what is
he's he's not by he's a pansexual as
well though just say Rebecca I don't
have the donor in the movie or just Ryan
Reynolds appeals to all things no I
think the character in the books is
meant to be pansexual I don't know if
they're gonna do in the movie [ __ ]
hope so
I mean this right now they're breaking
every taboo exactly um they've even got
a Stan Lee cameo Oh mom this is weed
Stan
um so this movie looks phenomenal
yeah I feel like a director do you know
um I don't know I don't know who Tim
Miller Tim Miller I don't know him
what Tim Oh Tim Tim Tim see in Chapter
Oh what you can't hear ladies gentlemen
is our producer telling us thank God as
we mutter amongst ourselves on dates
we'd have like the year but in yeah it
was like he says it there analyze rate
see no money I'll just there's now it's
all words on screen um the Tim Miller
manner pressure sitting around going it
Who am I who are you [ __ ] you you fat
[ __ ]
it's I'm the [ __ ] making the
movie you say you're really a [ __ ]
suck dick to see I'd said that but I
will say there
all right fair enough looks [ __ ]
crazy I like that it's opening I think
middle of February which is like the
Kingsmen slot now it's just been a
super-fun comic book movie slot did was
that also Fox
it was also Faso they've claimed that
way claimed like Valentine's Day like
Christmas to the old Santa Claus movie
Dudley Moore is beyond all yeah no like
they had weird Martin Luther King Day
because you need like an inspirational
black sports movie to open Martin Luther
King Day so what are they so they're
leaving Deadpool is gonna be it for this
year pretty like you will never cease
were traditional well is kind of black
right he's got red on him red lives
matter was what he do this is first
directorial debut alright so nobody ever
want to forgive us for not knowing who
so the director of Deadpool did opening
title sequences for some Marvel movies I
mean way to step up and I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if the dude is
like prior to this job they were like oh
is moving boxes at Cumberland Farms that
trailer looks amazing that trailer looks
like [ __ ] like I've been making
movies 20 years I got a trailer I'm like
what [ __ ] stop every critic on the
plan is like yeah dude if that's what
Deadpool trailer does hopefully the
movie make you [ __ ] kill yourself it
may it looks that good everybody's got
to start somewhere
yeah my kids starting at the tops to
Miller kid this kid he's got the world
by the balls I don't know who he is but
he's got a little by the balls and I
hate him
I did all the way don't do it's gotta be
older right he'll give kids
Deadpool today I mean I don't know dude
they used to give kids out of film
school just everything it's true man
it's true talented kids not so
theoretically not some kids are
throughout down a bit let's go so the
thing is you do um alright man so that
trailer looks really really great yes um
you know more of that [ __ ] please
more more like I see I've seen we talked
about the trailer for x-men apocalypse
if you can get Deadpool that right yes
can't you get the look of apocalypse oh
maybe they wanted to fix it in post and
the post fixing didn't happen is that so
yeah
it's what we don't have to we don't have
to [ __ ] kick them and raise we don't
have to put something down and raise
somebody up but it is the same studio it
solely is based technically the same
French look I ain't seen the movie yet
but I'm just saying higher that TJ
Miller boy
whoever it is from Kansas so hard to
direct every movie this movie looks so
[ __ ] good it's crazy it really looks
like how is this movie not gonna make
500 million bucks
because it's rated R I don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that that's weak but you're right
that might be well maybe able to be like
the new 300 we're saying like oh my god
the parents are more of this and then
everything then we can get an r-rated
Batman movie [ __ ] you know what happens
after that eat you with my dear
if Deadpool works DC does Lobo that's my
guess really I feel like like Lobo is
that what is the toughest one to crack
because it's so [ __ ] violent and it's
so out there and it's so cartoonishly
adult that somebody's got to tread those
words first I feel like if Deadpool
works let do it we don't care
intergalactic bounty hunter
sure planets exploding why not let's do
that alright let's slip it ball here
alright Oh if Deadpool works what does
that enable others to do like if you
were uh I've made you the mayor of
Hollywood yes please um you're allowed
to name do you know how loud to pick off
any project you want uh huh um in this
in that realm like weirdest you know
because you [ __ ] made Deadpool
because people like you crack the code
what is the next thing that's like holy
[ __ ] Deadpool without Deadpool that
wouldn't have been possible um I mean I
really enough in another one I would
have said Judge Dredd but they made a
Judge Dredd movie that's actually really
good
I judge movie oh good really haven't
seen it like see it oh my god it was
good but yeah just that like outlandish
sensibility like trying to push that
edge like I don't boo stir gold is a
thing you can maybe do feature wise
you're not as violent but you loose your
gold now though it's not like like
Booster Gold fits into a forgive me I
don't get crucified but Buffy ish
template of jokes while we have
adventure isn't sure
which I'm sure predates Buffy but that's
kind of the go-to reference for that I
you know I don't know I think you got to
go something where you're like I never
thought they could [ __ ] do that
Man Thing mmm [ __ ] Swamp Thing what's
one thing to have done
I remember liking martial law every
martial law yes holy [ __ ] Wow great
[ __ ] pole man I would pose this name
Kevin it's like oh god the artist you
know what I'm saying maybe wrong was it
Kevin Mills core Kevin O'Neill gives a
[ __ ] you know Millicent O'Neil are the
credits but I don't remember the first
name oh my god I haven't thought about
this book in such a dog's age this is
[ __ ] what say it again Marshall
Marshall ah what what a great book and
what a great pole Marc so smart it's a
it's a fantastic like in the vein of the
Brat Pack another great [ __ ] book um
you know kind of a skewed look at
superheroes but the art and these
culture violence and the sex name's Pat
mills Kevin O'Neill in when 87 87 this
going back to the glories say these kids
be a good comic after the Dark Knight
Returns people like [ __ ] it let's just
and in fact I believe it was a response
to the Dark Knight Returns Margiela post
that the other thing I would do in the
same vein of Deadpool is I would find a
way to do another Tank Girl movie oh
you're absolutely like I feel that in a
world where go give him a single is so
beautifully where Mad Max works where
like Ray is the biggest character in
Star Wars where you can push the
boundaries of taste and violence and sex
and language and all that [ __ ] like you
could actually do a tenth girl movie
today
that totally resonates yes you're
absolutely right and people would
[ __ ] line up see that movie in this
day and age to do the effects right and
stuff like that yeah look at just living
on that single was getting jealous is
that do I get any camera - uh what -
excellent polls dude I wish you were in
charge of [ __ ] man oh my god Andy you
can't see those movies go look at both
of those books right now oh god what ten
girl was what Jamie
you it you look Hewlett ya got your
[ __ ] scratching at the door my
distant [ __ ] collecting memories and
and I'm like oh my god proto dinosaur
brain is kickin and McGee
I loved martial law dude that's a good
book ah fool-killer I wish Marvel would
do fool-killer
that was a pretty good book I wish DC or
you know some vert maybe they will get
to it
remember vigilante and decent oh yeah at
the end of the run spoilers kids if
you've never [ __ ] read it I mean I'm
not suggesting go read it it's
indispensable but [ __ ] up at the end
of the run he's like what's the point
can kill yourself holy [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] movie man they're like why the
franchise died
as well you could [ __ ] [ __ ] with
things then he becomes dead man mmm nice
that's next bit if you can do uh what
we're talking dimple Deadpool ain't no
way you can't [ __ ] it dude dead man
mm-hmm
I wonder about the boys do you think the
boys will ever get off the ground
they're going to Garth Ennis yeah I
would imagine like somebody cannot opt
into wow I don't understand why Mark
Millar doesn't take you know like Garth
I always think of Mark Millar and Garth
Ennis like comics wise Mark Millar
happens after Garth and and I you know
I'm not like he owes this guy right but
Martin Maher is a very successful they
look to Felix paws it might be like we
gotta [ __ ] start the Ennis train man
Garth Ennis was like the guy before the
guys before the guys like in comics like
did a tremendous [ __ ] job he needs to
be working in flux and maybe he's just
like I don't want to work in place like
do whatever I want exactly whatever I
want [ __ ] comics I mean he's very
feature coming next year so it's true
finally finally yeah that's true
there was Rachel Tice it just goes back
to [ __ ] Tank Girl Rachel Talalay the
director of Tank Girl direct wanted to
direct the preacher movie right at it
and at one point me and Scott Mosier
were attached as producers we met with
Garth and Steve Dylan and you know we
were like dude we got no juice in this
business whatsoever but we what if we
can help throw our names out and [ __ ]
and it never went like it was you know
this was 1999-2000 so I remember Bob
Weinstein though like I was like Bob we
got to do this because he had dimension
he had done the CRO hmm so I was like
this preacher dude this is [ __ ] you
got it I'll read this man this is
[ __ ] the next-level [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] read it me the next day is like
Kevin I don't nag indeed this isn't that
the credal the CRO I get this is not
crew he was right mark
he sure his point I believe was that the
Crowes very easy understand don't like
my girlfriend's killed my girlfriend's
killed and you're gonna be in trouble
now he's the crow the [ __ ] crow
emo crusher is that [ __ ] um okay that
was simple constant vengeance come back
again rage yes and not too much
costumery and stuff this was in touchy
late 90s early 2000s when the costume
way crazy only Merchant Ivory movies
gonna cost your home yes the Silver
Arrows worse man this was like just pre
matrix where the costume was a black
leather trench coat until people start
to shoot up schools wearing black
village yeah no no like we better put
these people in there weird crazy calm
down please cuz nobody will ever go into
a public place like that if they do
you'll be like keep an eye on that one
no maybe that's why it all happened hmm
I'm fat man on Batman investigates some
award winning journalism coming out of
the show I'm now we're - perd hapley I
um I I figure I think going back to
Deadpool trailer you're right man they
cracked this [ __ ] movie like there's
nothing you really can't you at this man
then you can make with a strange tone
ups for grown-ups
and that'd be your target audience there
was a movie that just came out this year
cuz you know I was looking through the
list of movies cuz next episode we're
gonna do our top 10 2015 movie list yes
so not to say these are the best [ __ ]
films these are just the these the films
I like the most
gotta get careful people fish it not
best plus I got friends too
who like put movies out there like I was
on the list oh my [ __ ] like that so I
know a bunch of guys you run TV shows
where it's like kid safe it was lovely
you know Sam's great and I don't take
offense I know a lot of people like
filmmakers do your endless in years that
I have movies and I'm never like nope no
tusks
no no Muscat Tosca piece of [ __ ] right
Estate was you had your reward you made
[ __ ] tusks that's what they say I'm in
any event why did I bring that up mmm
2015 we're talking and we're looking
forward in the next day oh I was looking
at the list of movies mmm there's this
one movie that I like I don't I didn't
hear about coming out but I'm like holy
[ __ ] to hell and back hmm
it's a stop-motion movie looks like by
some of the cats that work on Robot
Chicken oh really and it's about like
three dudes who blog the synopsis
sounded [ __ ] incredible and I'm like
why don't I know of it it's a problem
there's so much content that comes out
on a regular basis dude that it's like
you can't consume it all like I don't
even know why I bother trying anymore
because that's what I like about
podcasts and particularly particularly
the audio podcast you just make it leave
it and not worry like someone will get
to it eventually oh yeah when you make a
movie you spend a lot of money and [ __ ]
there isn't a like hey man we gotta get
people to show ups make the money back
and stuff there's a sense of like we've
got this little window to do it all
podcast is just like leave it there
somebody'll find it when I was talking
to Mary the other day about James
bonding podcast mmm is it yeah we're
done but people are still downloading
stuff like people are still discovering
it even though there's no movie coming
out we're not making any more of these
you know I could but there's so much
content at this point it's crazy it's
tough to sift through it all hopefully
this show can be a bit of help for some
cats but you can't I can't even help
ourselves I don't even know this is a
movie I think it's called to hell and
back I don't know for this title but I
should have known about this movie
sounds like my kind of [ __ ] flick
like it's claymation or stop-motion and
three buddies like make a drunken kind
of pact with each other and like one of
them breaks it and gets dragged to hell
excellent and so the other two have to
go to hell to get them back oh come on
like that sounds [ __ ] done oh my god
hire me to sell the movie next
I just read a synopsis I was like this
seems like the greatest film ever made I
know I said that about Deadpool but this
may be it as well this film I haven't
seen might be the great hope died in
despair kids that's how I live um but
check that movie out so I'm gonna find
it [ __ ] look at it we'll report back
um what else we get is that's not wait
was there anything else Star Wars Force
awakens record talk about Star Wars how
can we not talk about Star Wars kids I
don't know if you know this but there's
new Star Wars movie yeah it happened it
broke all kinds of records all the
records it broke mark tell him what it
broke
let it be broke the big one is so far
fastest movie to a billion dollars mmm
in history that's probably the easiest
one like honestly all the other records
mean they're great but it's just like
that tells the [ __ ] story right there
fastest movie in history to reach a
billion dollars yeah there's a you know
website what is a box office mojo mojo
that does the side-by-side comparisons
they do of movies they do these movie
races where it's like you know sometimes
it's a movie and it's sequel and when
its sequel comes out they're tracking
its grosses versus the grosses of the
original and stuff they did one for
force awakens and avatar ooh
because that's the race and that's
that's way up top at a mountain man and
went 7 billion I think is avatar is that
where they are I think so others like
22.7 that's a [ __ ] climb by yes
they're already at a billion barely one
minute ten [ __ ] days is okay and it's
not like we've all seen it we're done
like I've seen three [ __ ] times other
people going back multiple times but
avatar at this point in its box office
run was it like 474 and I granted you
know you got to do
adjusted grosses ticket prices more blah
blah blah but his avatar wasn't like
Titanic so the ticket prices weren't
that [ __ ] far me so at the end of the
day like looks like Star Wars as a
really really [ __ ] good chance of
being the number one movie of all time
and it hasn't open in China yet which is
the second biggest market in the world
oh my lord so at that point right they
fuel inject the box office and [ __ ] it's
like yeah me [ __ ] like eight more
hours
shorty and chrome um it's [ __ ] huge
man and again it's deserved I've seen
the movie three times it holds up and
some people like [ __ ] you you're a shill
I'm not a shill as I am you know what
you're absolutely right I'm show four
things that I did and I dig this [ __ ]
booth I need to make apologies but a 45
year old man at this point in my life
I'm really not apologizing because I
like to see because I've built a [ __ ]
career on it for Christ's sakes Jesus
but um it holds up to three three
viewings yeah last time I saw a movie
three times in theater I wasn't even my
own that's out of that um was Dark
Knight Rises Rises yeah which I which I
you know I like this way more than that
yes but I you know I was like oh my god
[ __ ] bang I fell in love with that
performance so I saw that three times a
theatre within span ten days same thing
here yeah I'll probably see it like a
couple more times I care about the last
movie I did see more than words but it's
been a while it's been a long one been a
while you know what I saw when I went
back this time when Han Solo running
from what are the rap stars or whatever
they're called um he's running down a
hallway in a big balls behind him oh um
it seems like there's a ton of those
things whole movies chock-a-block full
of little Easter is that there's like
ray looking at the box that has the
lightsaber in it it is totally the
fertility Idol shot from Raiders oh that
really pushes in he's like right behind
it looking at it so that's why
everyone's like is very Spielberg in and
stuff likes very and it's very Lawrence
Kasdan Ian because Kazon also wrote
Raiders and so it's got a lot of that
pace it's got a lot of that like drive
and then they stop for like 10 minutes
if somebody can tell you plot right like
Maz Kanata has this whole scene where
her purpose is to just deliver
exposition yeah the same like those two
guys who show up with the giant Bible
I'm like well there's a thing missing in
the desert what is it we think Hitler
wants it why is it so important where
leader they stopped the movie to explain
to you everything you need to know hmm
it's an arc what do you mean it's an arc
what's that rays of lightning God fire
honestly mark I remember them being
their delivery being a lot better than
that
a little bit perhaps why are we doing
here what's your fine
you should carry the ark maybe open it
um you're right dude oh you're right
this is why you have a [ __ ] mark
barnard even breaks the [ __ ] down to the
atomic level subatomic level and finds
the Spielberg DNA hidden within the
force awakens there's this amazing
document online called it's it's a
transcription of the story meeting
between George Lucas Lawrence Kasdan and
Steven Spielberg where they're basically
breaking the story for Raiders to lost
on this is real it's real why is it
somebody is somebody because they
recorded their own 1980 they just had a
tape recorder going she was like this 50
page document that's just that commerce
that is more important than perhaps the
[ __ ] Declaration of Independence yes
to me
absolutely I mean grant and we will now
flash to the alternate universe where
there is no trickery her all in like
bondage [ __ ] it's shitty but okay
together
it's pretty amazing what happened I
don't know me for a funny movie should
have more respect for the dependencies
what you're out of a but it's
astonishing let's just don't watch those
three guys in a room forget that stuff
out and there is this moment where
they're trying to solve the how do we
give the audience information about this
and Lucas is like we're just gonna have
to lay a bunch of pipe here did you say
that it's like we're just gonna fillet a
bunch of story oh my god they're so sexy
it really is the sexiest Lucas is
everybody yeah we're gonna have to
listen fight hard you rent with force
dude look as the creator of sea you'll
have to explain your joke George hey I
do every other day um wow man I'm read
that look it up there's a PDF totally
floating around which means I bet you
there's a recording somewhere there are
those cats like there's those cats who
like it I'm vamanos vamanos cats
I'm doing a show online so probably I'm
happier that I'm not those cats I I
think most days but if I was those cats
like I would I bring out every [ __ ]
nickel in terms of like hey man we know
you would love to hear the story meeting
the great
Raiders of the Lost Ark so animated by
ILM s finest oh my god a cartoon you're
absolutely right they can make it
relevant if you make it a cartoon then
you could sell it I was just gonna like
put it up on a podcast they could have
done like the Georgian Steven podcast
something like this well you know that
like given that apparently there are
still like chunks of Arcana from the
Star Wars shoot that is open subsequent
DVD and blu-ray pressings or whatever
every time it's never-before-seen
behind-the-scenes footage it's like it's
been 40 [ __ ] years how have we not
seen all this everyone so my ask
somebody on earth some yeah they just
dragged some of that so I'm sure that
like for the next blu-ray pressing of
the Indiana Jones quadrilogy Sept illa G
whatever it's gonna be
that'll end up on there remember that
movie with was mr. banks saving mr.
banks or whatever they had the audio at
the end of the movie of the Sherman
Brothers and the lady who wrote Mary
Poppins and her like [ __ ] talking and
she sounded like Emma Thompson's
character like very much like you can't
do this you can't do that somebody had a
[ __ ] microphone on that it's amazing
it's crazy man like kids put a
microphone on everything
it's whatever just parents rooms or you
can hear it okay but just conversations
you have with your friend body cameras
come on guys in a world of body cameras
body microphones yes because everybody's
a billion good ideas you can counter
every [ __ ] day you're some you forget
to write it then when you get to be
famous you could just sell it lay it all
back right bring every nickel kids shy
of going to Burbank hotel and signing
autographs
that's the less I'm saving that for my
67 yeah when every week Jason's like
let's do it I'm like no - no we're gonna
save that yes for our for the autumn
year yes when we have car payments -
that's it go to 2-shot heavens
that's ins all the time we got right now
we actually we got way more time and
we're gonna put it into a whole
different show they can watch at the
beginning of the year man like January
1st we'll put it up so you could sit
there maybe a second or something like
know the Monday after January 1st there
you go whatever do that is yeah yeah
maybe Sunday for noon man but the idea
will be for us to look at our favorite
movies of 2015 so come watch and compare
notes with us bill you [ __ ] fat
jackass that movie sucked
or hey you fat jackass you hit one or
something like that
positivity is become witness with us as
we go through the list man spray our
mouths and [ __ ] be like we're there I
was like last year we wouldn't do that
in any event come back next up so don't
forget man there's still a podcast an
audio podcast good downloaded SModcast
calm come back next week man but this
wait this is the last episode of the
unit is I mean I know we only start at
the end of the year so it's kind of like
being a boyfriend all through December
New Year's Eve been like I love you
forever and like girls like we just
[ __ ] that we haven't even done
especially if you're a boyfriend like on
the 26th yeah when you like post
Christmas you dodge that like we got
this bit little used together right Hey
auld lang syne she's like Union give me
a [ __ ] gift dick that's what this
show is the dick where the did you again
something um yeah man this is the end of
the year thanks for for hanging with us
I've had a good time
oh it's been a blast come on where you
keep doing this man I hear about your
eight comments read them all below no my
people seem to like like what we're
doing I don't see a lot of hate well
they'll find us your other hate always
finds well it's like thick like the
force it binds us together for the
Internet's for the fabric of humanity is
eight come back next episode we're
talking about our favorite movies of
2015 man right here on as you could see
man
same bat-time same bat-channel here at
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey manse me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder